So that brings us to the end of the tool creation class.
Thank you for sticking with us.
Let's just do a quick recap of what we've covered.
So we talked about the theory of tool making, where a lot of it's about considering what you want this tool to do and where you would like this or how you would like this to be triggered.
We've then gone through four exercises and made a few different tools.
First, we started looking at construction script where we use that for a mesh scattering and we improved that so that it used the line trace to connect to the floor.
We then made an exposed function that allowed us to bake out the meshes that we had scattered.
Next up, we created an editor utility widget and we just used that in order to do another line trace in front of the camera and spawn meshes accordingly.
We created a function in this instance so that the same code could be reused over and over again.
Finally, we made a mass rename using an editor asset utility.
And as a final byproduct, we had a quick look at an actor action utility which demonstrated where we would be able to place a trigger connected to the right-hand click menu of an actor within the level.
I hope you got some value out of that and thanks a lot for following them.
Goodbye.
.